um
we are now seeing a new face of the war
because russia is really moving out not
only of kiev but also of uh most of the
north at least reducing significantly
their presence there
because they failed
president putin didn't manage
to achieve the objectives he set for
this military operation
his goal was to take care within days
now he has been there for so many weeks
and still
he has not been able to take care of and
many other cities
in the north
so he's now moving
many of those troops
out of the north
into belarus
down
to the east into russia
and there they will be remand because
men have lost
a lot of troops in the different units
they will be re-armed
because they've used a lot of ammunition
and they will be re supplied with uh
fuel and all the other things they need
food and so on to launch a new big
offensive so what we are expecting is a
new very concentrated russian offensive
in donbass
to try to occupy take the whole of
donbass
that's also the same
area where ukraine has
most of their armed forces
so
this whole build up will take some time
the repositioning of the russian troops
will take some times some some time some
some weeks
but after that we
we are afraid that we can see a big
russian
offensive in donbas
would aim to take
donbass
in that window
it is extremely important
that nato allies provide support
so we are able to rearm to resupply the
ukrainian
forces
and that's exactly what i expect allies
to do and what exactly what i expect
allies to discuss at the meeting
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
um including what homes what types of
equipment and how we can enable them to
stand up against and continue
to inflict heavy casualties on the
invading russian forces